[Musica]
volevo fare la sigla di milano jones ma
sono intonato come un istrice perderti
ragazzo che volete persone video sono
faringei oggi vi introduco a quella che
sarà la mia esperienza a tenerife perché
sono andato in vacanza penali per
quest'anno è stato bellissimo
ho fatto un sacco di cose tra cui anche
il paracadutismo c'è la terra parapendio
dove ti lanci dove il paracadute è già
aperto così è impossibile che non si
apra perché se conti tutti se non si
apre
poiché lì per terra un casino ma questo
era già aperto però mi sono caricato su
quale avete visto la copertura quindi vi
lascio ora basta corre a camminare
io camminavo dell'esigua chi cammina si
queste dico col mio corre si ri mero ma
tu sei garrone yoko perché io no sicuro
che è sì no no stessi importanti è
importante che un occorre non possiamo
la stima ok so io corro si prima di
camminare city e scorretto cammina corre
con decisione con decisione sì sì essere
un esercito che tu cammini corre ok è
facile ok ecco questo momento non me lo
aspettavo comunque avanti
da noi la terra della parola di carmine
siamo mette la mano
un'altra trama
siamo sicuri sicuro bueno lo so seguito
dirlo ma io mesto è veramente cagando
amico mio e semi aperto a terra io ti
offro a siena
premo 4
tu lo fa spesso no quante volte quanta
volta tutta risposta fossa s 64
come 60 e terzo significa trieste 13 sì
un cazzo ma almeno 300 a notte
è solo inutile ma niente
ormai che mai doha compagno
vivo questa gente va via a due stadio
sta bene frutta benissimo vamos a la
playa così perché stai veramente cagano
comodo vale ottimale pare proprio una
sega guarda
milano
e stato meno
i 92mila non va dall ara
mi chiedo
perché quando atterravano gamba rigida
oa began
con le correnti 3 con lei quando a
taranto
la playa
alla baia ora si chiede
quindi resta è stata la mia esperienza
in base ad un bar ape baracca pretendete
in dio
il fatto è che purtroppo ragazzi lago
pro si è spenta prima che noi atterrasse
muro però vabbè era finito il giro che
meno è stato fighissimo e sto imparando
lo spagnolo
spero che vi sia piaciuto il primo pezzo
di vita adesso vi lascio un po di carne
il latte di cose che sono successe
durante questa pac e shawn tenerife
ma c'è qualcosa
non siamo sicuri che la barca una
persona di tutto rispetto che ci tieni
in sicurezza mentre cinque minuti siano
affogati
secondo me se cercano le balene non le
attirano proprio benissimo perché sono
fan di latino americano le balene pro ok
ragazzi questo è stato la mia esperienza
dell'eni che spero vi sia piaciuto sono
adatto anche al parco acquatico il
numero uno al mondo sempre tenerife
quello invito a parte che credo uscirà a
sabato prossimo quando resto non tarlo
per adesso ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto e credetemi che quelle
veramente una bomba e non vedo l'ora di
farvelo vedere tra l'altro i ragazzi
problemi dicevano se non ti piace la
rete di esercizio questo detto senza
falsificate ci vediamo
birds
[Musica]